one of the name you might know me by
star-lord legendary outlaw hi I'm David
and I'm saying and last night we saw
guardians of the galaxy and we loved it
we super loved it yeah and I love all
the Marvel movies this is definitely
like just like Pixar Lee got like a
stream of just great movies one after
the other yeah well this is certainly
like phase two has stepped it up so
significantly but I think it's pretty
arguable like you could certainly make
it convincing argument that this is the
best Marvel movie so far and that's a
that's all right thing to say after
Captain America 2 Thor 2 Avengers Iron
Man 3 they have ramped it up so
significantly and it really gets you
jazzed for the next one I mean one of
the biggest differences though is for
instance Captain America's a really
famous character wears these characters
Rocket Raccoon tracks the destroyer I
think not everyone really knows about
them and I think gardens the galaxy
didn't really sell that many comic books
in fact it wasn't being published for a
long time so I think it almost has that
against itself but then it sort of
skyrockets past it which proves that how
great the movie is because you don't
need to know much about these characters
and you can still enjoy the hell out of
it well let's jump right into it so
first of all it doesn't really feel like
any of the Marvel movies which have all
had the bonus of we're building on a
world that more or less you recognize
and if you didn't recognize it you've
had two movies to get used to it this is
completely new it is the weirdest thing
they've done so far it feels like so
much more of a Star Wars movie than the
last three Star Wars movies that came
out but just from the standpoint of
character like a villain oh yeah and
people doing things that make sense I
mean this movie is not that plotted you
know like it's not intensely yeah
there's a straight MacGuffin that
everyone is trying to get this young Gen
or the stone and then that's kind of
everything revolves around that it's
straight through but that doesn't matter
because it's so character-driven yeah
you like all these people and you like
seeing them interact and it's done so
naturally
so well you know James Gunn just totally
knocked it out of the park and it does
feel like those cool space opera
adventure films of which you know like
2009 Star Trek reboot by JJ Abrams that
felt very much in the lake kid who grew
up watching Star Wars fame and that's
exactly what this feels like yeah we
thought imax 3d and just it was
beautiful to look at I mean there's so
many things like interest in the
background of like like just alien
creatures and such and there is a lot of
Star Wars there's a few other Star Wars
references I think they're sort of the
Han Solo Chewbacca relationship is a
little bit similar with Groot and Rocket
Raccoon yeah and then I feel like Peter
quill is also a han Solo I feel like it
with a ton of consoles makes to be too
hot mostly Han Solo remade Star Wars and
it was only hung solo han Solo was like
great job han Solo don't get cocky han
solo hit me this week and it that's a
great movie and that is a great movie
and you would watch a million times the
fact that Chris Pratt who's the heart
and soul yeah me had not anchored a
picture like this before you were used
to seeing him in parks and recreation
and then we recently saw him in zero
dark thirty where you definitely buffed
up yeah but also dave bautista never
been in a movie this size before if
Avengers is a movie about heroes who are
winners this is a movie about a family
who are losers yeah and it's just as if
not more enjoyable you know um I loved
it I think there were a couple of
amazing set pieces from a technical
standpoint it's beautiful to look at I
mean the motion capture is great the
characters are so well timed with humor
I think and I think everyone has
something they can relate to you with a
different guardian personally I just
really loved Rocket Raccoon he was my
favorite Sam who's your favorite
Guardian probably star-lord I really
think yeah that was like the coolest
dude he is he's like swagger on swagger
oh yeah yeah yeah you have a feeling
that back on board his ship he probably
has racks on racks on ya and stacks on
stacks on stacks
and tracks on Drex I dragged the chicken
Rex oh my god I can't believe I didn't
come on so yeah I mean the humor this
movie's definitely were my favorite
things as well as the fact we finally
get to see Thanos yeah that's cool and
we really get to see my was surprised by
how much he was in the movie let son say
anything yeah it was we won't do any
more spoilers beyond that we're gonna
wrap it up now so be sure to click here
to buy tickets at it doesn't work for us
because we're in this but for you it
would work so I'm gonna go see it again
this weekend I've been certainly
recommend it to anybody be sure to
subscribe let us know in the comments
below yeah who your favorite guardian is
what do you think of the movie just let
us know we want to know what you think
of the movie and whatnot alright awesome
thanks for joining us I'm Sam and I'm
David thanks for watching